ladies and gentlemen please welcome john
ciao
hi everybody
i am one of your biggest fans this is
nuts now i went way back
and on my research with you and uh oh i
cannot even like handle the fact that
you
change the world
when you set a certain line of dialogue
in a certain film
will you tell me about that
oh yes uh i introduced
my apologies i introduced
the word milf into the vocabulary
no apology is needed
i was once young
yeah
you don't age you look so good you just
have different hair yeah that's all i
see
did you know when you said that line
that it would become an iconic
catchphrase like forever it's still as
relevant now as it was then
uh no idea in fact i i that's not the
part i auditioned for i was kind of a
featured extra in the rest of the movie
and the you know we did uh a table read
and uh
i was the one of the people who showed
up and they said can you do these 10
parts or whatever and uh and and the
director said would you like to do this
other scene and so
it all seems really random but uh here
we are that sort of um i guess it it
launched my career uh
but um i i'm just i i'm so also excited
to
learn that you were a teacher
yeah um i had a
piece of paper that said i was an
english major uh when i graduated from
college and i
i couldn't get a a job waiting tables so
i saw this ad
and um so i taught english lit for a
year to seventh and tenth graders what
was that like
it was very
stressful it was an honor it really was
um but i wouldn't
but i quit that year after that year i
didn't go back to it because
it's important to be selfish if you're
an actor
and you can't be selfish if you're a
teacher
you have to live for the for your class
and
i wasn't prepared to do that at that age
[Music]